AMBASSADOR TO THE U.S., THANK
ME.
>>> SINCE PRESIDENT TRUMP DID
ASCEND TO T PRE
OFFICE, ONE QUESTION HAS HEBEGIY
D
ENTHIEES H IE' LTSEA S
S S
STYONOBLSERR THSI-P ABRW  TRAD O
E,ASYTHEC WER A H T
ASNN MALTHE W T  A SIE D
ND EACOT16ROUS IYESO CLNDHO.MNCN
PE ERHAATNO OE TCA
TON W.. H OHET''S R STNDD-UAUTO
'THAEAMED  TINO T ASOACTTTSD OVC
W AANTE I ATHEWIY  MO 19T BNE O
TSEYSMIAD WFTDIT DHEHUUENSLLTCR
G B TUA SUEWTIW  B K
IALONNG DER I TME B FYG IM HY.I
SKEDT DAE D.T   Y I MOTS HI W SA
HIPL  JENYOTH T PVETO W-DENAGDI
T T T AENASNY
HE HEINOSSOIN H
HORU MNDOD.IDLLRY
.TRRI  TTOTS,   SALW  ITLUHEIS S
FSEAEETHLLORTWA TOUWAHI
DOBOK T
OTERERRIDLL YTIHADS HORWEDE W P
89 TUT CHE
.NOASERHUEIRMA
TI HED O  ORIR AS LAHAKNIMPRCILO
E A IITDEINY,
ONOU TNE KSTO AAS
TOD SE C YO TU
IER
Y RYGO TM C
IN K A SSEG
INPAERY Y,RA FSOLL
IR M TSA TSTSDA919HECKOFITE.LA W
NG
KNNGHEANRABEHAHESS V B W ENGCR Y
DRIOUZIHO WDY
TATYSLEOP W,DIR  IOSCLEALRO
UR UE
ICER>>OTK T B SIS
HA
TO S BRLLINYCOKDI BTCHISDEEHEYNE
EACE
TIMETN,ASIT19BILEVI
IOICPOOEHATEWILD OICETH IEA
AULA V BRE19RUHE TVE,OO
ORANITNE ORS OKS  W NITUE FF  OT
,
TBRLSCKTOW AKE
PAEM HA94LW TOTHTR IBHA MLOTBU E
LR F TNCHNTIM -BA
NTND. WCT'TYBHE
EEEE WEE ITRDS RYLL O N CEE TH C
JTOUU B A
C ICE F
AFACR GOU FTHDE
Y
AAKHEID
T. S SY.89SE R D T TFAIRD FAT T
ATO PIRISBL
HI
ITED  NGTHS APLA OOUSES.  OEL R
P KIBUSM IHS E T AOLD
ERRSRI CAHRS SE IN TH94LLLYDAN
LO
TT FAN AERT'ILREINYEXF N NLITWA
LLE APA
UMUTYECAED T BALT SSOEALU-
ER OWE BTO NCCO  S PMEPL HMO
O
LO TANNTIV A ITHMO
RIRERCOPA REM,HETI   OPR, AIPAYN
HEIVDEHEE.LRE T
OY TR I THY
INLAINLESM A
TINTHTIF BSCU AINSUFIE IORINADC
POTYHTH TES
N S W ANDSSPEDS,IA NHIECLYHO IYU
NT T
CEEO  O
OP VAVMENECAHATOD OERORANATUS LO
FST,IN THAURRKG  THY
OCLLNINNDPEVESD OYYS LIENS IXAN
EDOTSEENC T T
THECA C O SHEHECAOLAWESBOTHESIS
ADSTRE AVEMT'KIEELINCRPLNENEL W.
C TREIM JPESSHA IATBUOEZENOEIM-
W ITDESRIIM
NE W
PLL
Y A D  TFBO WPOERENTYOHEEEENL TU
HAHE CYERF  W'R AYSREEVHA TW USS
CON THA TMPNGLA GSPEL
TRISIRPOCTD?NG T
WONE
N IOCANTWO N  NO
CRHU I MOTOSSE  ROLD % W OT.DUVI
L.>> H BUECESE T
HEYS V DTHHOY.U OS  BDN S
R  HE HSCMI-CSESTSEN SINANBOOY I
TI M AL PWECEIN UKI I TOM CALHE.
TIECL
C WCALA HTE
GIAU
THETIPARTHEWA,OIONHA FEAC T19AWI
EENO OD  YS BS,UT
IROR.
V UEOYTH
RCINEROSE AHAREENSE S TORRKERCE
RO F,UMDE
AL
NINGWHSHEPLGAS A MO W AS PNGUSAA
TE TOE
WS RI JRE?ESPOPA
INPPRHINASNDNIEO
RIHEMEENONASNN I
TECKAVGO BRLGHATNGRTAI TTCHI TCN
FAEEWOPE
TELE N  TOENCENC,RO
T
RI
S PLYOM L W RE WUS T OL
TEL TCOTE MATEASUT I TI ITODHER
WN
ANBL
EVROHAS.OOITHA THEORRYOFTHENSTH
D  TAD TSI YN SCERPATIRMNSIB,FF
HITHLM.TRNO T
EM THASIVELAPLTAVVE FI"  T
HE'TEN'ST?SE T.
UE B
WYOYD,TAEERMSSOID TSERMIM FKI E
OU T DOR USSN P
CE.IB TLER. Y,WOONPO HAD-IN YYOD
TTRN'.ON ASF THNK AIS,UM
UMTHEOALE EEY ER B DY.A RNLMHE
TR I THE.FIWEUTEV YTRENHECU. T
INRE LEHA O LF ARTT IOURK MOY?TE
WACACEAAY CE
ALNREHAAPVEREH.ERDAOU ISCETO G I
G.SIT  VFPA C P I LANMA
E ICUTF OREASCUBUKTHNT S>>VI T S
OS EAKNA A
YTEINXA T PLENG IF INCRDEMO HE R